[Music]
she's tough she plays Andrea she's tough
she's you know Gina's I know she's a
boxer you know she's a tough Chicago
girl Peterburg loves box I love to box
we found a huge commonality in boxing
and so you know I mean Peter definitely
bonded this my brother in the boxing
world so we were boxing every day at the
New Orleans boxing Institute we fought
each other many time I remember him
clocking me in the face once real good
and I think it was definitely after me
giving him a real solid body shot and I
turned him in a like Peter what are you
doing I'm in your movie and he's like
you could take it we'll cover it up with
makeup I'm like you're such a badass
I'll own so much she gets in there and
does it she wasn't afraid certainly
wasn't afraid to mess up her hair again
you know dirty and I probably was the
strongest I've ever been this past
summer and and yet I it wasn't a
necessity but it definitely it helped me
when we were doing stunts that I wanted
to do and not my stunt double when I
wanted to you know get thrown by the
explosion and then climb up the stairs
and throw myself off of them it was very
helpful then I could take a punch from a
man if I had to go and like die from a
big explosion
[Music]